Today, I would like to talk to
you about,
the concept of
semantic data fabric.
And, so this
session won't will
not be a lot
around the product
of Poopati. It's more around
the concept of
the semantic data fabric,
which, of course,
can be achieved by using tools
such as the Pool Party
Semantic Suite,
which is a semantic
middleware.
I'm working for
the Semantic Web
Company, which
is the vendor of
that product as Ellie said.
But I today want
to talk to you
a little bit about
this concept
of data fabric and
semantic data fabric.
As you see in my
first slide here,
there is another
logo on on that,
which is data dot world.
You might have
already attended
one or another session of,
the colleagues from data dot
world today. the reason why
there is this logo
on that is that,
data dot world and pool party
teamed up to create a semantic
data fabric by
combining the two
tools with using
their features
to the best extent to provide
a Semantic Data Fabric.
But let me talk
you through that
a little bit and I'll give you
some examples today.
I'll show you
a demo of how this
can look like and
I'll give you
some real world
examples of how
a semantic data fabric
can be applied.
So let's get started.
The first question always is,
why should you
care about this?
Why is that
an important topic?
Why is Semantic Data
Fabric an important
topic? And because
we are talking
here and then,
in an environment
of people working
in that field,
I think that's
not new for you.
IT systems are
getting more and
more complex, data
volumes growing,
and at the same time,
our customers or,
decision makers are
demanding simpler,
faster decision making,
very often based on insights
that are automatically
discovered.
So to do that we
need some kind
of tools, to do that we need
some kind of help
and the semantic
data fabric can
help with this.
I would like to start this
presentation with
an example Yeah?
Because I think
it's always more
relatable if you
have some examples,
to to show on how this,
theoretical concept
can be applied.
And today, I'd like
to take an example
from the HR, field
from the human
resource sector.
Human resource leaders,
very much face an increasing
pressure to drive
business value
and optimize costs,
especially at times like this
with the corona
situation and so on.
they feel that
pressure a lot.
But optimizing
costs in HR should
never be a one off exercise.
It should always be an ongoing
discipline and it should look
beyond just cost
cutting to find,
should, just look beyond cost
cutting to find
real efficiency
gains while not risking long
term business performance and
have a negative impact there.
Well, that we all
know is easier
said than done. So
taking that example.
One issue that
might be that not
seeing the full
picture of your
employees skills and expertise
can actually cost you a lot of
time and money in
your company.
an employee might be spending
time to solve a problem slowly
or using very expensive
consultants.
When on the other hand side,
he or she could solve it much
faster and affordably
by working
with a colleague
who has already
that relevant experience
and knowledge,
in that problem space.
So one essential component is
always to see the full picture
of your employees'
skills and expertise.
And again, that
sounds simple,
but it requires
a lot of different
things, especially in in in
large companies.
It requires to have
the possibility
to connect and reuse data from
various different
data sources.
It requires to put
data in a semantic
context. It's not just enough
to have access to the data but
you really need to be able to
connect the data
in a meaningful
way and I'll show
you in a second
on how this can be
done in this example.
You will need to be able to
react fast and be Agile.
I mean, we all
know that that's
what we always need to do,
what we need to
provide and that
means there isn't often not
enough time to
just start another
big project to set up another
system to build
a new data model
and so on.
And so typically the challenge
that we have here
is that the data
and information that you need
for this is siloed
in disconnected
systems. poor data quality is
very often the unintended
consequence of data silos and
also
the unintended consequence
of poor data and
analytics governance.
So by combining
this unstructured
and structured data,
let's think about
the HR use case again.
that might be HR databases,
resumes on file servers,
assignment lists to projects,
articles written by your staff
members and so on.
So by combining
these structured
and unstructured
data you really
can start optimize costs and
boost productivity.
by better matching your people
to the problems and the tasks
and by helping them to team up
with other people who already
solved that task or who have
expertise in this.
This example I'm using also in
at the end of
that presentation
in a small demo that I'm going
to show you. but now let's get
back to the concept
of the Semantic
Data Fabric.
So what is the Semantic
Data Fabric?
Well, the essential
of a Semantic
Data Fabric is
it's always built
on existing
investments in data
infrastructure.
It can leverage
the existing data assets like
your data warehouse,
your data lakes
and all the things
that your organization
has already
built. When you think about
the concept of
the Semantic Data
Fabric you always start by
cataloging your data assets.
By making an inventory
of the metadata
that describes your data and
making that catalog available
to the organization.
That's the very first step.
For that, the data
warehouse and
the data lakes are
very important
here because we
need a place to
store the data.
We need a place to govern it,
to run our jobs, and so on.
The Data Catalog is
then the jumping
off point for providing access
to that data resources.
And from there
you can start to
harvest the knowledge of your
organization to
answer the questions
about what is contained within
these data sets,
in the catalog.
What do they mean?
How are they connected?
And this is where
the semantics
of the Semantic Data Fabric
really comes into play.
It's about
capturing organizational
knowledge in
a structured fashion
with using linked
data as an essential
piece of that semantic data
fabric concept.
This semantic layer that I'm
talking about here is always
formed by an enterprise
knowledge graph,
which creates a uniform and
unified data environment.
And because that enterprise
knowledge graph is
such an important
component of the semantic
data fabric,
I would like to go
into the theory
of that a little bit to talk
about what is that enterprise
knowledge graph.
So as I said it's
a centerpiece
component of the semantic
data fabric.
In order to build
robust systems,
that are really accurate and
manageable in the long term,
what we need to
have is we need
to have a layer
between the actual
data and the content
and the application
which allows you to query and
join the data from various
different sources easily.
So when you look at the model
on the right hand
of that slide,
that you have in front of you
and you start
from the bottom,
You can see that
we start off,
with the existing,
data sources,
which are very often as set in
unconnected silos.
Above that layer,
there is an additional virtual
data layer that links
all your data.
Let it be structured
or unstructured
data. This is
basically a graph
version of
the existing data and
represents the relationships
between your
database content,
your document repositories,
your datasets, and so on.
And then there
comes the domain
model of your knowledge domain
in place and this is very very
important part of this.
This is the third
layer in this
four layered architecture and
it is the so called
conceptual model.
We also refer to
that very often
as ontology and you have heard
that today definitely already
several times.
As well as
the linguistic model
referred to as
the taxonomies.
So by the combination of that
conceptual and the linguistic
model and the virtual
data graph
really represents
this enterprise
knowledge graph as we call it
and as we have it
here as a centerpiece
of the Semantic
Data Fabric and
the applications that we build
are really sitting
on top of that.
So let me make
a quick, quick,
excuse into a topic that I
personally find is a very,
very important
one when we talk
about this. We call
it the Knowledge
Graph Life Cycle.
Why am I mentioning it here?
Because it's very important to
understand how
such a knowledge
graph is actually built.
How is it maintained?
How is it improved?
The most important thing here
is that a knowledge
graph always
means that humans and machines
need to be able
to work together
in an agile way.
We call this
the human in the loop
principle.
So you see here
we have a we we
think that the human is a very
important component of this.
It's not just all about fully
automatic automatizing
everything.
It is about the combination of
the human and and
the machine.
So the development
of a knowledge
graph is always an endeavor
involving several stakeholders
and it's important to map them
out and we try to do this here
in this in this picture.
there are three loops that are
always working
together and that
are interlinked.
Let me start with
the first one
in orange on top.
This is the so
called user loop.
Here in this loop
business users
and data scientists interact
with the data.
They are not only
data consumers but
also data producers.
Then in second loop,
the blue one,
bottom left, is the so called
expert loop.
In the expert loop,
the knowledge engineers,
the subject matter experts are
modeling your knowledge,
your domain knowledge,
and they work on that,
conceptual layer.
So the taxonomies
and the ontologies.
And then you have
the third loop,
on bottom right,
which is the automation loop.
In the automation loop,
the data engineers
are involved,
they do data cleaning,
transforming,
enriching of data
and all these
three loops,
really work together
and the working
together is really
supported by
the machine. So the aim,
of this Knowledge Graph life
cycle is always
to have a balance
between these three
most important
perspectives of
a Knowledge Graph.
First one is we
want to represent
the domain knowledge
accurately.
Second one is we want to link
company data and the third one
is we want to enrich it with
user context.
So but now let's get back to
the concept of
the Semantic Data
Fabric itself.
This one is a very
important thing
to just keep and
remember when working with
knowledge graphs but let's go
back to the Semantic
Data Fabric itself.
If you think of the semantic
data fabric a bit as a data
catalog meets semantics,
then certain themes
start to arise.
it's all about discovery,
sharing and finding all sorts
of metadata and the data they
describe and doing so based on
semantic models that refer to
real world entities
and relationships.
it's so it's when
we talk about
the data there it's not solely
based on the physical location
and the layout of the data but
it's always about the meaning
of the data.
When using the Semantic Data
Fabric concept you can always
also leverage natural language
techniques to
process unstructured
data and synthesize it with
structured data sources.
It's It's a very important
component because you start to
be able to link structured and
unstructured content
and understand
the content of
the unstructured
data sources.
Then the knowledge you capture
is always linked
together in a knowledge
graph and I mentioned
that before
and I think I
emphasized already
quite a lot how important that
central piece is.
And as a last
point I would like
to mention that you always can
use machine learning
to automate
or enhance data integration on
top of that strong foundation
that the semantic models and
the semantic infrastructure
metadata catalog
has already built.
So let me guide
you step by step
through how a semantic data
fabric is built.
Let's start with
the first step here.
And you see again,
there are the two logos,
this pool party and
data to world.
So this is now built
on the capabilities
of the two tools and how they
work together.
All of it starts
as I said with
what you've already built.
The data fabric is
never a greenfield
type of deployment.
It's essentially
always deployed
in an active and
heavy populated
data environment.
So, the pattern is actually
designed to be something that
can be integrated
into an existing
environment. and
you catalog and
connect what's already there,
what's already in existence.
and that can include
data sources
like I said, data warehouses,
data lakes that
can include web
services, APIs, file shares,
knowledge bases,
data analytics,
data visualization
platforms, and so on.
The assets to be cataloged are
the tables, the columns,
the files,
the notebooks,
the dashboards,
the data dictionaries,
business cursories,
taxonomies and so on that are
already represented
in those systems.
So this is the real foundation
and it's really important to
note that the data
and the analysis
are critical to catalog
and understand.
The dashboards and the queries
and other bits of existing
analysis often
contain the most
important knowledge about what
the data means,
how it's been used
in the past,
and how it might be leveraged
in the future. So it's really
important to understand
what's there.
Then as a second step,
there are several
components to
an active, data
catalog building
towards a data fabric that is
built on top of
that, foundation.
There are catalog agents to
automate the process
of extracting
metadata from the systems.
Data can be integrated into
the data catalog
via ETL processes
or it can be virtualized data
can be integrated
in virtualized
fashion as if
the data would be
in those systems.
And the key of all of
this is semantics.
Again, we want to integrate
the data into fabric based on
what the data
means in terms of
the real world relationships,
not based on the technology
choices made about
how to store
and manage data.
And to do that, your
system needs to,
one very important component
that both data dot world and
pool party are built upon.
And that is
the knowledge graph.
And here we come to
this centerpiece
again. The knowledge graph is
really the centerpiece
of the semantic
data fabric.
It is the part that allows you
to bring in your
domain knowledge
to link your assets and enrich
it with Semantic Context.
So now having
said having built
that foundation we can put
something on top of that.
On top of that,
we can put
a semantic middleware
such as the Pool Party
Semantic Suite,
which will allow you to enrich
your data.
so for example
semantic standards.
Just to name some examples,
you can also use artificial
intelligence and
machine learning
to achieve, active
metadata management.
And of course,
you can leverage
natural language
processing and
deep text analytics,
for example,
to process your unstructured
data and bring
the unstructured
data into context with your
structured data.
Finally, what you
obviously need
is an efficient data delivery
and data integration component
to make all this enriched data
available to the users and to
other applications.
This is what a smart
data catalog
such as data.
World can provide
as part of the semantic
data fabric.
So this component and and just
ensures you have
efficient ways
to present your
enriched content
to the users. And here we talk
about the well
known things like
powerful search, user
friendly browsing,
access for other
systems via APIs,
webhooks, and so on.
So with the semantic
data fabric,
just to summarize,
you can connect your data,
make your data visible
and findable.
You ensure that your data can
be understood and
interpreted.
You ensure easy
access to the data.
You can offer smart tools for
data curation, and you will be
able to gain
insights and create
impactful outcomes
from the data.
And now I would
like to show you
just a quick example.
We have built
a demo to showcase
this based on the two tools
mentioned Data.
To2world as a data catalog and
Poopati as the semantic
middleware.
And we thought about what is
the best use case
to show it and
we are using a real
world use case,
a business case
that is that we
actually very regularly hear
from our customers
and partners.
It's about semantic
matchmaking again,
in that, HR field.
So the business
case here really
is a consulting company wants
to quickly find
the best consultant
to be assigned to
a new project,
and they want to do that based
on skills and
expertise matching
to the project.
The challenge that you very
regularly have,
in in in that
setting is that,
again, data is held
in various places,
data silos, and in various
different formats,
structured and unstructured.
And the matching is therefore
often done based on personal
preferences or on insufficient
data quality.
So what we have
here as a solution
is we are using the semantic
data fabric approach
to access the data,
to enrich it based on semantic
context and use the enriched
data for an application.
So let me take
you through this
step by step and
then I'll show
you the demo. First,
we have data from
various sources:
CVs, timesheets of
the consultants,
project descriptions
in just a text
format.
As a second step we
use the strength
of data. World
in Pool Party to
do four things:
we access the data
in an augmented
data catalog can
be in virtualized
manner. We ensure that we have
efficient data delivery and
dynamic data integration
capabilities,
again via the data catalog.
And then we are
using the semantic
middleware to
utilize the tools
and features for
semantics based
on a knowledge graph.
And we also use
natural language
processing techniques
to process
the unstructured data.
And all of this leads
into a semantic
data fabric
powered application
that allows us to
do the matchmaking
as we need it.
So let me show you
that example here.
I'm just looking at
you can see that.
this is our semantic
matchmaker demo.
You will find
the link at the end
of the presentation.
You can try it out yourself.
What we have done here is,
here you find a list
of projects.
They are just
imported from an open
data source of
the European Union.
This is real life project
descriptions we
have just imported
from an open data source.
So I just click on one random
one of this list.
What I get here is
I get the project
description, in raw text.
So that was
the project discrete
description we got from that
open data portal.
As a first step,
I can create a so
called semantic
footprint. So
what we are using
here is we are using
a knowledge graph,
which has over
twenty one thousand
concepts of skills,
occupation,
topics, and so on,
which is, by the way,
also built by
the European Union and,
available for free.
And we use that classification
to build a footprint
of that project.
So Pool Party has now created
a footprint of that project
based on the description.
And in the next step,
we match it with consultants.
So we are now taking,
data from consultants,
and I'm just
clicking on one of
them here.
We have in the data,
data catalog,
we have data from
the consultants.
They are CVs free
to so again,
unstructured text.
We're creating same system.
We're creating a footprint of
these c of these people,
and we are matching them to
the projects. And what you see
here is a just one
to one matching.
So we are matching
footprint to
footprint. That's
the first step,
but we can go much
further than that.
We can enrich
that footprint or
we can enrich that
matching with
using the information
in a knowledge
graph. So all the relations,
all the knowledge that's built
in the knowledge graph can be
used to further refine that.
And now you get
much more precise
results because
we're using all
the knowledge that
is in the knowledge
graph to make
that matching not
just based on a one
to one matching,
but based on the meaning of,
the data that was extracted.
And finally, what you can do
also is you can, use
structured data.
In that case, we say,
consider experience
level based
on structured data,
which basically
only means that,
we had assignment sheets,
how much time
consultants spend
on specific projects.
You're using that structured
data to further
enrich the result.
And I'll leave
it at that point
because that, is
just giving you
a quick walk
through on how you
can build a semantic
AI based,
application of semantic data
fabric based application,
that immediately
gives you much
better results for
such a matchmaking
project and that
uses all the data
structured and unstructured in
a very easy manner.
You just can upload new data,
you just can integrate
new data sources,
and this application will do
the matchmaking and
provide results,
for you on a day
to day basis.
Because I know that time is
already quite, advanced,
I'll skip my two examples and
I'll leave it with this.
if you're interested
in that concept,
please feel free to
reach out to us.
there is a white paper that we
have written together,
data dot world and, Popati.
feel free to download it.
you can try the demo that I've
just shown you briefly.
And if you want,
to have an a more detailed
conversation with
us on that topic,
reach out to us,
also in Slack,
of course, and
I'll be happy to
answer your questions.
Thank you very much.
Fabulous. Thank you,
Florian. Yes.
There is a booth for Symantec
Web Company at the Slack,
which you can access,
and he'll be there.
And just to let you
know, Florian,
we do go until ten
past the hour,
so we have about
fifteen minutes left.
okay. We have a few
people typing
in the chat, but if you want,
while we're waiting
for the first
questions, you
could maybe share
those two examples.
I'm happy to.
let me just go back to my
presentation then.
So I just wanted
to give you two
other examples because I only
talked about, the,
the, HI use case.
But of course, there are other
use cases or other business
cases where the semantic
data fabric,
concept can really,
really help.
One could be you can predict
equipment failure
more accurately.
So this is for example,
when you work in oil fields,
replacing equipment
like an oil
field pump can easily cost
millions of dollars.
And therefore,
you need to really
anticipate when
it will fail in
order to provide
life extending
maintenance and to plan for
the placement in time.
and to accurately
predict that failure,
you need data from various
different observations,
from reporting,
from different systems.
This is again an example where
semantic data
fabric integration
can help can help
a lot because,
for example, you
have all field
engineers very
often enter their
observations into
maintenance logs.
This is again
unstructured text,
but that contains
the very crucial
context that needs
to be matched
with the with the structured
data from other systems to be
able to predict,
such, such failures,
in in time.
So a data solution
that understands
and links the text from that
unstructured, maintenance logs
with the other data
across the different
sources can really improve
predictions here
and easily save
millions, actually.
And then very obvious one is,
around customer experience and
customer knowledge.
when you have
customer calls in
a call center, you always need
to solve problems very fast.
You need to keep
your customers
certified. You need to retain
their business.
and the information you have
about them in your database,
in the single
database that you
have in front of you might not
be sufficient.
But you can find
very valuable unstructured
information about
your customer
on the web, in social media,
in other channels,
and you can easily start to
augment your understanding of
the customer and the problem
that they're experiencing.
And so this enriched view,
that you can create
here can really,
provide your
employees that are
working in the call
center with
a much better understanding of
what problem solutions
they can offer,
what cross
selling opportunities
are there, what upselling
opportunities are there,
and which ones
will most likely
succeed with
a given customer.
So I just wanted to bring in
these two other examples here
because we focused
on the AI example,
which is quite obvious one.
But, I think we can find in in
every domain, we
can find an example
when we think about,
possible applications
of a semantic
data fabric. I'm really glad
that we had time
for those because
I agree that, you know,
concrete use case examples are
very easy for people to wrap
their heads around
and and begin
to understand what
this powerful
connected data can do.
And especially when we talk
about oil and gas
pump replacements,
I've heard about this before,
and someone has told me an oil
and gas engineer has said,
if you hear
the pump that makes
no noise, this is
the one that's
gonna blow. Right?
And so if you know that this
costs millions of dollars,
it's a it's
a little bit easier
to begin to explain the value
of this kind of investment.
So we have, one question to
begin with in the chat.
Thank you, by
the way, Florian,
for the excellent
presentation.
Many compliments are coming in
for you as well.
Pallavi's question is,
would she would
like to know how
domain knowledge
goes into graphs.
Human intervention is required
to make hidden
domain knowledge
explicit in unstructured text
or documents. Is
that correct?
Yeah. I I I said it's both.
It's, of course, on
the one hand side,
it's the people who
have the domain
knowledge. so one
of the things
that we are really,
really that is
really important
when we develop pool party is
that the component that allows
the subject matter experts to
build a knowledge
graph is very
user friendly. So we thought
from the beginning,
what is really necessary is to
enable the domain,
the subject matter experts to
build that knowledge graph.
Because you don't want to have
to explain all the things that
you know about the domain to
an IT person that then write
some kind of code based on,
on what you described. No.
What you want to be able to do
is you want to be
able to develop
that knowledge graph,
in an easy way
and it should be
developed by the subject
matter experts.
So that's the people part.
But then, I also
said that it's
always important to combine
the human part
with the machine
and there you
have possibilities
to automatically
create knowledge
graphs or parts of knowledge
graphs or to enrich existing
knowledge graphs with certain
technologies. So
in pool party,
you have features like linked
data harvesting, for example,
where you can,
have this linked data sources
and automatically
create a first
knowledge graph for you based
on on a specific
topic that for
example is already
done Wikipedia.
Or you can use existing,
knowledge graphs like the one
that I we used
in the demo from
the European Union
on skills and
occupations.
You can use that pre existing
ones and amend them
for your needs,
so you don't have
to start from
scratch every time.
And then the third
part what you
can do is and
that's talking to
the unstructured data that was
mentioned is there
is something
in the tool which is called
the corpus analysis where you
can upload thousands
and thousands
of documents and
based on those
documents the system creates
suggestions on how
you can improve
and demand and extend your
knowledge graph
because it starts
to understand the concepts,
in in that document.
So it's, as I said,
always the combination
of the people,
the human beings that
have the knowledge
and the machine
supporting them
to to create
knowledge graphs,
efficiently. And
the right tools.
Right?
Because it's it's much easier
to do this in
pool party versus
pen and paper or
even web protege
or something like
this. So thank you.
Kindly answer. We have another
question here from.
How is
the seamless integration
with the data dot world and
the data catalog
connected through
the semantic models
in pool party?
And how is the front
end endpoints?
How are they bridged?
So what we have built here for
that specific case
is that there
is an integration
built between,
Data. World and Pool Party,
which integrates,
the Pool Party extractor into
the data catalog.
That means that the demo that
I've shown, what you can do
there is you have your data
represented in
the data catalog,
can be uploaded to the data
catalog or accessed
via virtualization.
And then we have
done an integration
into the pool
party extractor.
That means that you can just
press a button,
send all the data
that you have
in the data catalog to to use
its text
extraction capabilities
as analyze,
and assess
the unstructured data,
and Poopali sends back
all the annotated
, and enriched data to
the data catalog,
and that's again
stored in, our,
startup formats
in RDF format.
the enriched data
is stored back
into the data catalog.
So it's a seamless integration
between the two tools.
The modeling of the Knowledge
Graph happens, in that case in
pool party, the data is stored
in the Data Catalog
and the integration
between the two tools is done
so that you can easily submit
the data from the data catalog
to the extract and get back
the enriched, data.